it is undeniable  that if donald trump were president  right now  more americans would be vaccinated there  is no question because the people who  follow science  who are vaccinated today  would still be vaccinated if trump were  president  but there would be millions of trumpists  who have not gotten the vaccine because  it has been joe biden overseeing its  rollout  who would have gotten vaccinated if  trump were president now the second  question is tougher would we be better  off as a country  that's harder to say because trump was  such an unmitigated unmitigated disaster  i i think  long term we're better off with joe  biden rather than trump  even though you would have more trump is  vaccinated if trump were president but i  fully admit  the people that care about rhetoric  rather than science  they would likely be vaccinated at a  much higher rate if trump were president  today